[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast it's all you garbage yeah I'm
your host Dage Foley sitting directly
across from me self-appointed piece of
trash from Northeast Philadelphia Kevin
Ryan everybody hey guys happy to be here
real quick to the listeners please leave
it a great review real quick jump on
that that's important to get this puppy
off the ground you know what I mean
Cannon five stars or rhythm kid rate and
review even if you don't like it rate
and review it you know what I mean just
get the numbers up let me tell you
pieces of [ __ ] something [ __ ]
subscribe to this goddamn thing rate
review and [ __ ] cuz we're banking over
here
sickness five years put the [ __ ]
money in the basket
oh are you considering all the putty has
to be one joint podcast five years I'm
considering seven years he doesn't
really I'm here he doesn't really
understand what a podcast is to be
honest with you this is new right yeah
this is brand new you're like creed
bratton of podcast I don't know what it
is but I can get you one somebody opened
up a word doc and some God get your
thoughts out this is going to nobody
you've written it just know do time for
nothing it ends up on a thumb drive
somewhere you guys are actually both
ladies and gentlemen that voice you hear
is our very special guest this week on
our you garbage is our good friend he
has a brand new special on YouTube right
now
it's called life begins ladies and
gentlemen mr. my canon oh my goodness
self-appointed piece of trash as well I
mix it is garbage my canon you know who
stinks
we did three we did three pretty one
pretty we did three pretty close to home
guess for the first three episodes okay
well we knew it wasn't me
too much of a mystery gotcha did he in
finance trade uncut he's like the
cocaine they made at the beginning of my
test a hundred percent blue or whatever
absolute trash garbage you can get you
could get him yourself cut him up and oh
yeah yeah yeah you could add baking soda
yeah you could step on him and sell more
girly
yeah his generous generations after him
for yeah
probably the next four or five hundred
years he's will be magic garbage yeah
he's trash and then we have a little
Canadian garbage oh and who's that see
we can guess is it Nathan yeah Nathan
yeah my first guess would have been Alex
Pavone you think so he's trash yeah
Alex's good friend of ours but Alex like
Alex has this weird thing where he is
trash right clearly very clearly yes
trash but outside of that he's also
Italian but like Italy you are yeah it's
a little different there's there's also
a thing between late trash and like all
my parents are immigrants same thing cuz
it's just like different customs and I
know it's a delicate subject yeah not
exactly you know pay homage to whatever
horseshit he believes sure pressure do
you think you're you think you're
garbage you think this is my thing you
grew up garbage my dad's from Levittown
long hair and my mother I think we wrap
right here pet my mother's from Jersey
so I you know you're in yeah yeah I grew
up outside of like do you know where
Highland Falls or West Point yeah yeah
it's beautiful up there so West Point is
beautiful Highland live in the slums
yeah well the town it's so funny because
you drive to West Point and West Point
is this like magnificent natural like
this and [ __ ] it's unbelievable
everybody is like via you know as as
show discipline didn't you Toffoli
then the town to drive through it this
island fall yeah which is like almost 8
mile - it's like hardcore and there's
the cannons like you did the best show
in fireworks with like one [ __ ] one
strap over in our overall yeah like no
shoes yeah it was like you know there
was the [ __ ] hardcore urban people
slinging crack that
[ __ ] near the school and then outside of
that was you know straight up trailer
park really I didn't realize you were
from that far up yeah yeah well I was
born in Manhattan okay and then my
parents lived in the West Village and
then that was the first place that I
lived but my dad was still commuting
into the city every day so he was
driving an hour no wonder he was not at
one point in that commute that was he
like moved closer to this yes didn't
afford it so he was a bartender still I
think trying to be an actor but he had
no like work ethic or anything like that
so I just kind of sat on his ass while
wait then he became a stockbroker
just keep doing cocaine but in a suit
sure nice was that in like the 80s or
90s like junk bonds and stuff it was
like hey if you have a tie in a white
collared shirt you can be a stockbroker
I can see the suits now the suits were
nice oh and a three-button and it went
after actors because they were like you
guys talk yeah yeah yeah have a little
bit you're free during the daytime for a
couple of weeks to get on my feet you
know I went there to with my dad when I
was like nine ten years old I would go
with him to work and what didn't work
did he work on the floor no he didn't
like the East Village
it was boiler room oh yeah but I you
know it's like [ __ ] this [ __ ] that all
that stuff cause like young yeah I
watched like I have this memory but you
never know if it's made up and I have so
many of those but I I my father's
co-worker I know this happened and I'm
pretty sure I was there I watched a guy
get cuffed by the FBI Wow I feel anytime
[ __ ] awesome yeah yeah I did that a
lot any time you go to work with your
parents that's like a pretty good
indicator that you're trash oh yeah
cuz it's like there's one there's no
babysitter or like they have these weird
hours dude you know many times I just
sat in an office and just like just like
wander around cigarettes I would do my
dad he was
owner of like HVAC company algis like
like pure dog like blue collar and then
he got a little bit of money he's like
we're doing it and ended up taking like
a whole house of cards cars getting
repo'd new money like new money and I
would just go to work with Ivy go
through people's desks and [ __ ] I was
like yeah I was I didn't know anything
your hands were smaller though tighter
space yeah exactly eatin people so I was
like a fat kid from rummaging through
everybody's desk on a Saturday when I
was a little kid my dad he was stationed
at that a naval base called Avoca it
looks very there was no word on that big
naval the neighborhood that's Melcher I
was there my sister used to go to the
music camp during the summer so
wilkes-barre music hat I think the
college and it's actually like a person
nice colleges up there I think college
yeah there's some nice colleges up there
fry I'm but again it's like the people
that live by the college or [ __ ]
trash right right and I had performed at
Mohegan Sun so who knows I got a weird
sliver of what's out there right up
Chernobyl USA oh yeah yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] sucking down cigs and whatever
an oxygen tank a crazy thing is back in
the day in the 50s and 60s the 40's
whenever it was a powerhouse it was a
[ __ ] huge bottling industry huge
train industry huge trucking industry
coal was huge up there it was all night
bragging valuable narrator of the
documentary no four woke spot and a
certain element it was a bastion of
American bottles as far as the eye could
see white faces everywhere and then
these hormones [ __ ] PVC goddamn
Asians and their better products tank
the whole US was PVC pipe yeah so crazy
that we literally bombed the competition
the Germans in the Japanese back into
the Stone Age during World War two it
took like 20 years 15 years to come back
my god thanks for that speed now left
I'm rebuilding yeah okay what the 80s
were all right
it was all worth it just for the [ __ ]
in every capacity I mean it looked cool
in the movies yes Wilkes plays trash but
but my dad he was stationed at the voco
for a long time and they had like things
there you know I mean like they have
like trucks and stuff like that and I
remember him taking us to work and me
and my brother literally playing around
like munitions crates yeah I run a tight
ship up there oh yeah yeah twisting the
things that's fun when you realize the
things that you considered normal in
your childhood yeah you know we owe to
bounce everything that's gone that's
happened to us off of ppea and that
helps I don't know about you but it
helps me kind of you know underwear away
what's normal and what's fun of course
that's well that's kind of where this
came from so there's like a game there's
like a 20 question game play at the end
it's but that's kind of where this came
from like we realized like oh we're all
[ __ ] trash yeah you know I didn't
even like you think I'm like I'm all
right and then I took back I'm like I
grew up driving a forklift as a kid
right for fun I'm like I'm [ __ ]
garbage you have an extended amount of
time on a high reach or a forklift
you're [ __ ] trash didn't everybody go
to AAA with your dad when they were four
didn't they
when did you start working what was your
first job 15 I think or maybe a little
early 15 I think I busboy Busboys always
let go they go - yeah and then I also
did that's the Gateway in the garbage -
you see you see because you've never
been behind the scenes in a restaurant
before then all of a sudden you get the
slap plates oh you [ __ ] they see how
people really are time you make coleslaw
you want to do you recognize exactly
what a restaurant is yes
barely a kitchen no oh yeah yeah folks
you've ever made coleslaw you're [ __ ]
garbage yeah yeah you just massage
mayonnaise entire carved lettuce that
you don't thinkI slicer remember the
sweet waitress that you thought was so
nice when your little kid
get a job at the place and you see what
she's really like scratch off lottery
tickets putting out cigars yeah crankin
Marlboro 5000 out back just like you
want one sweetheart I'm like I'm 12 I
guess yeah I remember working with
waitresses like that and they would just
come in in a bed like career waitresses
sorry there's a there's the attitude of
a career waitress that will never ever I
might answer career bartender and you
get it yeah for sure
I mean I say career commedia see where
this quit go of course and like being a
career waitress at a place where you're
about to like maybe clear a hundred on a
good night if you do that like that's
that's a mindset of a comedian that is
doing a hundred dollar road game of
course yeah yeah it's the same thing
well there's also there's like there's
like the big bubble or it's like the the
career waitress is the tail end of that
is tough you know and I mean because
it's like a good-looking chick in her
20s there and she's just like dude there
man looks like the lady that did the
cigarettes and the commercial some of
her fingers are full-length
most of them are yeah by the end of it
yeah but in the beginning do they're
making like [ __ ] I'm doing a tartufo
little brats birthday I'm gonna talk to
father but like they're making like you
know a fit they're making like 1,200
bucks a weekend cash and they're like
this it's like stripper money you know
what I mean all the sudden that it lasts
a little longer than a stripper because
they're like in your 30s and 40s but
then at some point you're just this 50
year old person trying to make a hundred
bucks on like you know wing night or
something like that stuff and their
advice is how forgiving from career
waitress they don't hold any punches
just like yeah you know so whatever
you're thinking right now that's not it
really just know like it's gonna be a
life of her yeah right like a male
friend they're like like you know how
people in movies they show you falling
down a cliff and they Scotty yeah and
then you're at the bottom life is
there's no bottom yeah yeah yeah there's
no bottom
you're just humbling forever just like
peak you know [ __ ] Con Ed bill
[ __ ] car insurance bill just [ __ ]
whacking you on the head Michael don't
ever get lured by a man with journey
tickets
okay he's not worth it cake they got
banged in a truck in the six sticks
County but dude I had no idea you know
my Aunt Sally what up girl don't you I
mean probably I have enough ants that
it's to my mom's on a nine oh there's my
mom's life so it's like do we are like
ticks in Philadelphia it's like Irish
Irish okay otherwise yes yeah yeah so my
grandmother my dad's mother she almost
died during her seventh pregnancy and
birth and right after that like during
the thing she you know gave birth and
they're like if you if you get pregnant
again you'll die you know you you you
can't get pregnant sure so my
grandfather don't you [ __ ] tell me
bastard yeah well this is how this is
how guilt-ridden and deep the [ __ ] runs
she goes to her priest and is like can I
or has the priests come into her
hospital bed it's like can I get my
[ __ ] tubes tied so like so yeah so I
don't have to [ __ ] do this any other
no I don't really do this to save my
life basically and the priest they are
such hah yeah did everything Cox base
coats will do whatever will be [ __ ]
[ __ ] excuse like I have you die
that's I'm gonna you know it also will
be totally fine with when she is died
you know when she does die not to take
any of those kids in sure Oh father
struggle for the rest of his life yeah
yeah both having to watch them hear
drown for the next 20 years it's
ridiculous dude one time we were
probably fingering one kid well for sure
yeah when we're such [ __ ] guard like
my fan there's so many of us I want to
ask you because don't you have an aunt
that has like a name that's not a real
name I got a couple and oh yeah anytime
you have an aunt with like a nickname
this is Barbara's you have this because
she's from Texas uh no I got an aunt
soupy yeah like that I got an aunt Quinn
II
that's not her name's a Kathleen
there's a couple of it I can't think
whistles that's like a real Boston
Philadelphia
oh yeah it's [ __ ] real trashy [ __ ]
yeah and soupy and cookie-cookie
what's Quinny because sue me I assume
she just threw hot be farting through
some sort of stool at somebody I through
shepherd's pie in a man's face that's
why I got me named soupy but one time we
were out in a bar as like me is like me
my brother and we were all like [ __ ]
up shot at the Mad River Old City
Philadelphia real [ __ ] trashy like
put on your best button up your [ __ ]
light denim jeans and just like go to
town you know Jersey sure was [ __ ]
hot yeah bunch of like Red Bull and
Bacchus and we were just [ __ ] hair
gel oh yeah [ __ ] cheap change oh
you're not talking you're fighting yeah
sure so I never had fights we were we
were there and this uh there was a
bachelorette party like as well and they
were like oh we need somebody to dance
on or whatever you know we need the
Bachelorette has to give somebody a lap
dance like to mark it off her [ __ ]
[ __ ] list or whatever whatever game
they play you know the game where they
try to get the woman to cheat on our
show that game yeah that game that's a
great game so yeah the night before back
to back to your family Kevin so then
they were like all right so like they're
like they like grabbed me and I'm like
sitting there and then they like the the
Bachelorette comes out of the bathroom
and she's like give me trying to give
you like a terrible lap dance or
whatever attractive absolutely not
cut - we find out I hear some one of the
girls like she was in the bathroom or
something [ __ ] another one of the girls
that wasn't there when they chose me to
give me the lap dance comes up she goes
Kevin what are you doing and I'm like oh
this isn't good like you know and I'm
who's that it was my cousin here the
girls like related to me all right here
we go let's get the [ __ ] out of here
she's like that's uncle Dennis's nephews
kids so I'm like all right here we are
no no no she wasn't lapped it was like
it was like you know it's really bad it
was my and potato I've read I read it's
not that bad to have sex with like your
second or third you hear that pornhub
what the [ __ ] who told you that one
couple of periodicals I subscribe to
some literature yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
cousins quarterly do what you got to do
I try my best to clear the family as we
aim for a first cousin if he fall on a
third cousin and that said I would be
going against my entire family's
heritage because in Ireland both my mom
side and my dad side are from like very
similar areas and Irish in general we
are a product of hundreds of years
inbreeding yeah yeah yeah yeah like you
know you think this head was pulled from
two different gene pools in your [ __ ]
no way this was our sunken eyes
no way just like clans like de you know
like towns next to each other it was
just like overlapping you know you're
gonna do it's [ __ ] raining potatoes
you know what I mean yeah I never
realized how garbage the Irish were I
mean it's gone everybody's garbage yeah
everybody's know I mean I though the
last few weeks I've been like trying up
and just talking to people about my rage
and I'm like blaming it on being Irish
and all this stuff yeah yeah you know I
got similar rage issues because I'm
Turkish understand what everybody blames
their heritage yeah it's a human that's
what it's like a human thing of like oh
we're all [ __ ] trash I see the
Russian rage a lot that makes a yes yes
quiet range we don't have things to
[ __ ] about but classic Irish thing to
say you know we don't have real things
to both Russian everybody else is valid
cuz yeah born in a small town in Russia
the same year you you were born in
[ __ ] wilkes-barre PA what are you
talking about
we obtained the TV and [ __ ] like that
you lived on the Iron Curtain
how would freedom could you imagine no
TV nearly no decent I feel like you grew
up in the movie October sky Youngjae
long gee I thought it was Gyllenhaal -
you sound like a pretentious [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah Gillan homes especially after
I said it I know yeah yeah
[ __ ] turn missus Espeon shocking -
funny - good we're having a good time my
candidly stop cursing is our guest I'm
trying to stop cursing the new special
is out right now it's on YouTube club
life begins I like I like the plug but
you're also acting like people just
tuned in mid mid replug that I do yeah
I'm gonna reset the show on the eights
you know we got weather coming up free
does that I think because for sure
people don't listen live but sometimes
they skip ahead yeah yeah in the
beginning and stuff alone especially if
you're Jared's show where he has
segments comes out the segments in its
description so he does I've seen it I
get 16 minutes you can go here Bill
Simmons does it - it's a smart technique
I just felt my intensive yeah my podcast
Irish goodbye podcast available on
iTunes today that is also more free full
of flowing Tim yeah yeah and so we have
no I saw the clip you just posted today
were you - how are you incredibly high
oh yeah yeah it was an editing trick
right no no no in the moment like so
it's such a I explained it so we were
really talking about but we talked about
Feeny just like you know expressing love
and coming rainbows sure and I just
agreed with him saying that that's the
closest that it's like a rainbow
shooting out of your [ __ ] uh-huh and
Feeny liked it he just goes I like dick
but there's the perfect length of pause
in between you go it's like rainbows out
of your ass Oh pauses for like a half a
second too long you're a [ __ ] someone on
here and then goes I like dick yeah it's
it's great
cuts back to you and you're just like
kind of like bleep it like because I
know I let him I let it lay because I
knew I wanted that isolated yeah and I
didn't process why he said it and he
tried to just move on yeah and I turned
to the producer [ __ ] I was like can we
cut that and just have that as a drop at
all times
something like cuz that was so and
Feeny's like what and then I just jumped
in and said something about like how I
liked everything he also likes dick
that's great too funny Mike and
gentlemen my canon life begins is the
special would just kill me yeah Jake
upon the traffic I said we get into the
game let's play a little are you let's
get into the game but take a look let's
find out about this dirtbag over
Rockland County can I ask why you want
to stop cursing I want to stop cursing
on stage no kidding
yeah I'm leaning into it what's the
point oh dude why it's what I am off
state I curse a lot
I'm [ __ ] you know not to fall on but
it's like I'm a [ __ ] trash like I
grew up with all like [ __ ]
steamfitters and plumbers I grew up on
job site so I'm like at this point now
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that's all that's what I grew up
you're you're a potential NBC sitcom
person yeah you can still be the nation
and I have no yeah you've you fit it you
fit a role you fit like you're very
you're a good actor you're funny and
gregarious and that setting Kevin and I
are I feel like just you know we got to
hopefully sell our personnel sure thanks
for tuning in to our you garbage ladies
and gentlemen I'll share something with
you when I was a little kid this is our
trash yeah was I always wanted to live
on the set of one of those Disney shows
that's because your families that was
like paradise as an adult you be that
producer what I feel like those pretty
easy easy hunting yeah I feel like those
chicks were pretty hot and probably
pretty dope it's like living on a
preservation growing baby fish in a
barrel
come on now no just like that reality
just looks so appeasing I think that's
why I do like you know one of the else
it comes yeah when I was young all I
wanted to do was be famous like I didn't
know what I wanted to be good at yeah
like that that's funny yeah I because I
took hip-hop dance classes I wanted to
be an insane I would have taken the
opportunity be you just answered one of
their questions on here
not not play it's not but you were
closing talk by some middle-aged white
woman likes named Sally no as a black
woman who's an soupier but I would have
taken getting molested by Lou Pearlman
in a heartbeat have my there seemed like
pretty good days when he went the
Pearlman had all those guys it seemed
like pretty good for them I'd be an
o-town I mean they didn't get any money
but get plunged grab some of those kids
uh yeah I think so there was like there
was a lot well they not all of them were
kids like someone were like at the point
like 19 or 21 or 2007 from Backstreet
Boys was like 48 yeah and he would jerk
alt like he was like make passes out I'm
like you know there was like naked
pictures he Blake uh can you you know
hit my computer or something and the
screensaver was like you know his dick
out or if there's like weird vague
passes I'm sure it was [ __ ] some of
those kids cuz he had like a group of
them yerim he had multiple groups that
he was then like pin and against each
other like a real today's the 99 yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it depends if you were working
finance financial services in the East
Village real barnburner pay the coke was
better than the eighties and nineties to
probably was better in the 80s yeah
probably oh yeah yeah no nobody knew
what it was no I mean people are like I
can make more money off this I've done
pure cocaine once and like you know pure
says sure it was like 40% but it was
like fish-scale straight off of a boat
in my eye like from Miami yeah my buddy
had driven from Miami to New York and I
have so many fans I just it was like
watching the food thing go up the the
piping in the mail sure yeah yeah in a
male in a post office it just shot up
your nose and you're just like long good
forever I will never blame you guys
tomorrow yeah you don't even have to do
more yeah it's pretty awesome yeah this
has been cocaine this has been are you
cocaine let's talk business I got one
right after that all right it's a little
personal yeah I asked you a question you
and a member of your family have an Audi
we did we did when we had money my dad
had an a4 Quattro no oh you mean howdy
belly buddies
oh that's weird I thought you met the
car - yeah yeah no but howdy out he's
kind of a car that it's like I got a
little bit of cash and this is how I
think rich people spend their money
real rich people don't have Alex even
occur to me that's so my dad had a BMW
he had an Audi he overextended himself
yeah it all came crashing down in the
crash of o3 right when I was heading off
to college I'm talking I was a budding
superstar talking bellybuttons no you
got an Audi your [ __ ] I don't know how
that happens
no when I my family I talked it was good
so is it a dot it's like a cut thing I
don't know my son doesn't have an Audi
because my wife has like a surface belly
button yes I'm not an Audi yeah it's not
in any it's almost like [ __ ] yeah yeah
when you're a little kid you see that
kid at the Swim Club or [ __ ] a belly
clip just happened here have you ever
been in a strip club with a family
member
ooh that's trash no no so so this this
could be counteracted by how Irish and
like sure yes well that's yeah you know
I was the same way but and that's what
made me think of it I went out with a
bunch of cousins and like brought my
brother and something I was like this is
this is a strain cousin this is strange
maybe I've gone with my cousin yeah but
I don't know I've gotten into fistfights
with family of course yeah yeah yeah I
may have gone to a strip club with my
one cousin I don't think so though cuz I
think the Irish discomfort with
sexuality and that it's like you don't
even like yeah yeah that's how it always
was for me and then like I did I went to
them I'm like this is yeah and my brain
mother the two sides of my brain were
like this this is my family especially
man I'm trying to like talk about it on
stage and I don't know if I can get
fully get across the potency of the
discomfort oh no yeah whenever anything
sex would be brought up it just like it
felt like a molestation yeah dude I
remember like any time like there would
be like a sex scene on TV or something
I'd be like oh my god like change the
channel or like look out oh dude you can
feel the tension in the way I saw my
sister's bra and came and freaked out
Kito while she was wearing it it was
awkward
it was cool I I don't ever remember like
I know that being Catholic [ __ ] me up
I know it you know I mean in being Irish
but I can't really pinpoint where like I
don't remember my hand that that is the
most Irish Catholic thing you saying you
don't remember I gotta remember priests
st. sex is wrong because I don't
remember anything it's all that like you
know kind of like how they say like
microaggressions it's all these little
things overtop subconscious all over
time we're like your parents had never
been like I've never mentioned sex and
any time they did they were like
something came up they would all look
away I change the subject so it's like
all these little things were that you
know just kind of reinforce that I meant
even if it's even if it's presented as
like a secret thing mm-hmm like like you
know whatever like we can talk about
even if they sure I could talk about it
but like you know out of public view
that's a that's like a subconscious
shaming that it shouldn't be spoken
about yeah yeah yeah of course I think
I'm more [ __ ] up than I realized
yeah you totally are dude what the [ __ ]
you you think you're even close to
normal is crazy the only thing specific
I remembering and this this did like
[ __ ] me up was when I was getting
confirmed the teacher that we had that
would teach us the lessons to her
confirmation she told me she told us
point-blank who's who were learning
she's like if you don't say the forgive
you know nothing act of contrition
something what our Father but it was it
was it was like now you lay me down to
sleep but then I'm more Syrian myself
[ __ ] Metallica ya know but she said
if we didn't say that that prayer before
we went to bed and we died in the middle
of the night that we would go to hell
that's true that's true yeah that's like
I mean that's I don't think it happens
but in the plan like yeah I was like in
[ __ ] fifth grade man yeah yeah man
it'll [ __ ] you up yeah yeah you know
well it's a religion and all religions
are this way but religion is based on
control sure that type of [ __ ] it's it's
intentional yes I am to [ __ ] you up so
now they have the answer like oh well
you got the answer I'm with you I'm
looking to you well and also they want
to keep you scared of course yeah then
you behave yeah
pretty smart welcome to all right
Kippy what do you got have you ever worn
Jenko genius did you begin to go out on
that one so this is this is how brutal I
am also have a follow up has served in a
chain while connected yes oh yeah
there's been several different
variations of Jane Wald's I what kind of
class yeah I mean I was just a kid
that's been searching for an identity my
whole life yeah that was kind of the
same guy was like a skateboarder at one
point I was like if I wanted to play
golf and while I went through the
skateboarding phase like everybody else
but I'm mostly like kind of I wore
basketball jerseys and stuff like that
went out of style 10 I wore janko's but
I only had what age was the janko's like
eighth grade I guess seventh eighth
grade probably maybe six through eighth
eighth ending it a little bit then I
kind of got back into my sporty but
janko's I my family was such a piece of
[ __ ] like not even pieces of [ __ ] but
like everything I wanted they always got
me like the diet version I know I had
Lee pipes which I was really upset about
I wanted janko's and I got Lee pipes so
I didn't even get those I just got genes
like they just got me genes that kinda
had a little like big G weren't even
really big and then like I I'd get like
you know I I was into rollerblading sure
I was pretty good through Putin but the
aggressive rollerblades they were 150
bucks so my parents would only spend a
hundred yeah I get like [ __ ] hole skates
couldn't do what you wanted to I have to
take out the to middleman like that so I
had one pair of janko's that my buddy
ended up borrowing and then he cut the
bottoms of them because they were too
long him I was like yeah they're my
pants and they're supposed to be big
pants to begin with the first $50 pair
of pants I have yeah yeah but if the
bottom of your janko's aren't muddy
you're not wearing you're not cool dude
for sure
so you had like you know the floodwater
denko's yeah but I had you know what
about that I'm remember I'm like ashamed
no we're getting out do insane clown
posse no no never but I tried on limp
Biskit for sighs I tried
a little bit I buddy Rob actually carved
corn into his arm
corn was a big one with the or that all
so I had I didn't even have Jenko jeans
I had Genco khaki pants
Porter Manson yeah you know what I mean
your Sunday's best for them for the
douche bag the J was not the crown yeah
J with the crown that looked like
graffiti is a so cool as an eight year
old or eighth grade I was so cool it was
a bubble letter J rainbow yeah they were
just the worst on every level
yeah you were failing it a lot of things
right there yeah but I think I they're
like also available for twenty bucks in
a sale rack sure and that's why that's
why that's what you got of course yeah I
was I was the same way
we got the knockoffs - I was I want I
want a skateboarder do you guys movie -
younger mothers the company Nash yeah
that's plastic
yeah but the trucks were plastic yeah
yeah I had a Nash locals-only skateboard
it was like this [ __ ] high off the
ground possible do you want to sound
like a real [ __ ] door I didn't wanted
to get into skateboard it was like be I
did get into skateboarding but this like
I got one of those that like Toys R Us
or whatever like the plastic trucks and
the plastic wheels yeah you know sounds
like or whatever so then I started
talking to kids in school they were like
oh yeah what kind of trucks do you have
and I'm right I don't know but I [ __ ]
need new trucks like I'm going home to
get [ __ ] trucks right now so we went
to the cool skateboard shop was called
g-spot yeah that [ __ ] it was a big
purple building called G so I went in
and like the guys like everybody's a guy
I was like a [ __ ] skateboard shop out
of a movie in the night in like early
2000s and I walk in on my couch
okay he's like what kind of deck you got
I'm like oh I didn't have I don't have
any of these answers I really didn't
know and he's like yeah we go you know
world industries I'm like I don't think
so he's gonna do some I got up things
Incas and then finally he realized this
guy is not as this kid is not a
skateboard he has no idea what the [ __ ]
he's like do you have a Nash I'm like
yeah that's what I got is like yeah
these don't work front you're bored I'm
like alright I'll see you
[Laughter]
yeah I tried saying my favorite movie
was rad I never seen it but somebody was
talking about it the other day well it's
probably me my son after the [ __ ]
lead character so I movie for pegs on
them too I had a mongoose with pegs yeah
time I was four into my you know
whatever and then I died no I don't know
guy knows were being Dino GT or
something nice and then when I played
when I was playing poker and winning a
lot of money I bought a bunch of Heroes
wait how old are you playing poker is a
eighteen nineteen real yeah I played in
like all these underground clubs yeah it
is the same I did the same thing yeah we
had underground clubs we would go to
yeah absolutely trash you know how you
know you know you're you're really
[ __ ] pure garbage when you make a lot
of money in underground poker and then
by bicycle by John come over right the
quarter pipe yeah dude I've been opening
on the top wouldn't build a quarter pipe
I did this like at a spare wood from my
dad's shed I had so many times made the
thing too abrupt like it's like hitting
a wall I lit so I raced down my dad was
watching and I'm like I got 10 - Kitty -
it's like I drove face-first into a wall
and my front tire popped up the whole
bike popped up I ditched the ligh over
there and then I landed on a peg sliced
my whole [ __ ] ankle on the peg and
was just like that hurts so my dad's
like doubled over laughs that sounds
like a great guy we used to steal wood
from construction that was big yeah
auction site it's a new neighborhood
that was getting behind your
neighborhood dude to want this is we
were and so my buddy moved into like the
new neighborhood first right so like he
was like one of the first streets done
so we went in they had to build the rest
of it one times we went we're in the
basement and somebody took like a big
five-gallon bucket of caulk like took
the top off and just threw it on the
wall like the house was it was like a
concrete wall and just threw it on the
wall then we just went around and just
started sticking stuff in it for the
next day we were [ __ ] Oh
Woodcock the the keyholes to like the
Bobcats closed and stuff we were just
[ __ ] [ __ ] I know in the winter I
got a question
cue it up did you alright or any members
family ever owned a remote-control car
good one good like I got like a trick
one yeah yeah we had a Big Mama you was
like work on it and like you had to
tinker with it yeah a few times like it
would get up to like 35 you can quote
the speed of your remote-control car
your [ __ ] trash it was from sharper
image though I think this is also around
our money so that was a nun actually
family no I that's what about ATVs your
favorite ATVs as a kiss so we didn't
know him one as a kid but my dad owns
one now wow post-divorce
that's a garbage pail kid made good
right there Yeah right exactly that is a
Levittown shanty who finally had his
dream come true but I've never ridden it
I've never seen it I've never been
invited to see it that's very Irish
Catholic they were always scared of them
because in the 80s they were like real
dangerous they didn't have a lot of this
still David yeah this one kid got
paralyzed some ridin one so that was
like the big story
yeah it's gliding around with a straw in
his mouth another tool of fear yeah do
any of your family members still smoke
cigs inside yeah yeah I think I think
like people in my dad's side yes I'm
like a [ __ ] green couch and their car
goes up that type of [ __ ] I mean my
uncle Johnny did all that stuff but he
died before he could continue to us a
piece John alright P Johnny but he's
like he was ridiculous I mean he was
this guy so this is this is this is the
two-way street to Irish kids can go
right so my uncle Johnny and my uncle
Billy are in there well on that
is a pure in if you have uncle's with it
whether you couldn't just call him Uncle
John and Uncle Bill Billy John yeah my
Uncle Tom he's coming over he's gonna do
the cabinets in my Ma's kitchen yeah
steals our percocets so my uncle Johnny
and uncle Tommy and Jimmy something
Gorbaty and it's an Irish that's an
Irishman Italian thing that my dad
killed Nicky
yeah the worst heavens are the worst
yeah they are everyone comedy calm
everybody so Billy and Johnny were in
the West Village apartment right this is
like in the 80s and so it's kind of
rough rough neighborhood still to this
day there [ __ ] it was like downtown
Beirut yeah so they're taking the
elevator on their Barrow Street
apartment which is now like unbelievable
right Barrow Street apartment they take
the elevator down to the first floor and
they notice that a woman and a guy are
standing there and the woman looks a
little in distress she just looks
uncomfortable and the guy is kind of
like you know looks like a sketch ball
almost homeless type looking sure so my
uncle's are like Oh should I forgot my
keys upstairs I'm gonna head back
upstairs and so they stay in the
elevator and the guy and the woman get
in the elevator and the dude pulls a gun
on both of them pulls a gun gets all of
them into this apartment right makes my
uncle makes my uncle Billy tie up my
uncle Jesus guy ties up my uncle Billy
my uncle Billy tied up my uncle Johnny
loose though the porn i watch trashy
brothers the woman doesn't even get
involved yeah so so my uncle it gets
tied up loose right and the guy is about
to rape the woman aah in front of boat
so he he like starts to try to rape them
or rape her my uncle [ __ ] Johnny gets
out bursts out yeah here we go runs up
to the guy hits him the dude
shoots him in the stomach white shoots
him in the stomach my uncle Johnny
keeps punching the [ __ ] out of us on
that Irish guy the guy loses the gun my
uncle grabs it he puts it in the guy's
[ __ ] mouth and my uncle Billy is like
Johnny don't do it
we got the communion next week don't do
it Johnny
so so he like I think a little Michael
Jesus Johnny we'll just take turns in
the brook daddy why is it always like he
did have every right to shoot the guy
yeah but he didn't he ended up not like
it took some cokes Johnny's got a
conscious on him so my uncle he's got
the conscious Billy Johnny Billy Bobby
Tommy Johnny [ __ ] could Will Hunting
they get written up in the paper it's
like this big thing my uncle Billy are
heroes yeah my uncle Billy becomes a cop
the guy who didn't get shot yeah he
watched it cokes they talked them out
like I'll never be that hope that that
hopeless again wow I'm gonna become a
cop
my uncle Johnny became drug addict
holding people up in jail with him
before he died trauma he had trauma
[Laughter]
what a story
yeah it's crazy right yeah that's [ __ ]
awesome God he coming I can see I'm like
looking in the mirror oh now he's a
comedian Jesus yeah I can see him
looking at his wife like Debbie I gotta
do it I gotta become a cop it's my duty
well that's like another trash thing is
like to them so since I started doing
comedy into an okay to a my uncle each
other like I can holiday and one of my
dad's and my dad went back to acting
which is the classic the city can do it
oh yeah there's one way out of this
loser can do this
yes I think that's the same with Brian
Regan he's got like two brothers that do
comedy as well guys guys don't in on
again you know it makes sense funny he
has your mop work I mean he's back
selling stocks in East Village
he doesn't commercial he's on a
commercial right now for like old tinder
I don't know what it's called but it's
yeah it's just his dusty hair bleh
lookin good like I just wanted as I can
get later my Irish knuckles and a lady
[Laughter]
check it out do you have any any lottery
winners in your family not my family but
my wife's family really yes she trashed
she's Italian
yeah just like just normal Italian trash
yeah yeah nothing too crazy and her
family has it's not trash it's just like
it's like weird Italian stuff it's just
funny sure yeah yeah a weird cultural
yeah yeah it's very murky yeah I got a
couple you kind of already answered or
from the stories already I probably know
the answer ever been shot witnessing a
rape in a West Village apartment and as
that said uncle ever going to be a drug
addict give me other Uncle Mike caning
yesterday anyone in your family have
ever been involved in a pyramid scheme
yeah yeah Thank You Jess I'm sure I
don't know you probably don't even know
but yeah those answers you've already
given I'm pretty sure everybody knows
looting the cop canon family own a
timeshare um that's a good question yes
at some point somebody yeah my Uncle
Jimmy he became a stockbroker and he
just looked made uh instantly like
instantly was really good I'm wide open
back he's also like he's one of the net
he's like he's like a naturally funny
dude one of the funniest people I've
ever met he didn't stand up twice killed
and was like I'd be I think you told me
about that like why would I keep doing
it you guys are [ __ ] idiots so when
he got rich he bought like a boat of
media yeah
shares up the ass all that's that's
always the kiss of death man so I asked
you about the lottery thing because
there was like one or two really big
lottery winners in wolfberry that like
our family knew yeah and one was that
the Millers his kid Bobby the Miller
that's a trash name right there he went
through like 2.5 million dollars we all
kind of hit the lottery cuz we're white
yeah true I recognize my privilege yeah
has anyone in your family ever applied
to be on a reality TV show
I have okay which one I mean probably
real-world I think yeah what's up this
is Mike oh dude I want a black e I'm
being I want to see that day yeah I
wanted to be like good-looking and funny
so bad and I just didn't know that my
mom and my everybody in my family was
like just telling me how attractive but
I'm not Zack Morris show not like you're
not like I'm not yeah Cahill and you are
the hot guy yeah attractive yeah I'll be
1d friend all right I got another you
kind of I know the answer to this for
sure I think have you ever wanted to be
a rapper and follow up have you ever
bleached your hair yes yes yeah I don't
know rapper kind of like I'm super into
hip-hop Shore when you said I took you
took a hip-hop dance class I'm like yeah
it's but I also like when I would I
played basketball my first two years of
junior kasher and I was one of two white
junior college that's an overachiever
right yeah yeah well that's because my
dad lost all his money in the oh three
collapse so my sister got to go to
Indiana University and I got to go to
Rockland Community I didn't okay it
actually is a good school for those who
use it correctly like it really is
because it's one of they pay you to say
that yes it really comes for semester
it's not too shabby but it was a couple
years ago smoke
yeah yeah so it's high school with sig's
that's exactly yeah it's so funny
good-looking girls went to Community
College I remember yeah and their dolts
yeah I end up his career waitresses
drove siroccos and [ __ ] a Scirocco
it's like a shitty hatchback car long
story short I was I was one of two white
kids I had an identity crisis sure I
wanted to be as urban as human of course
well that's what you're surrounded by
like if you're like oh this is my you
know I wore Pelle Pelle jeans with
patches rock tabla la la I had white on
white Air Force Ones and I for a little
while I they should tape up with the
with the shape up yeah it also toes
Porter Rican coz I could dance and you
bleach when you bleach your hair like
that was like mmm really did it was like
we were like when he dropped you went
into school the next day and everybody
had bleached their yeah but my Oh Slim
Shady yeah
but first my mom did do like we always
did the diet thing like oh you're not
bleaching your hair
we started with Sun in and I'm like I
look like it's awesome I look like a
[ __ ] loser lady also got this
blessing skateboard is ain't going well
for me I'm like I you're spraying like
yeah you're spraying shooting here that
I'm hanging out outside for nine hours
as a pale Irish kid didn't really turn
out I guess it might have been a
conspiracy to just get kids outside they
could have been maybe that's what
Michelle Obama's campaign was missing
sunny sunny yeah yeah yeah but I had
these wiggers don't want to want to be
rappers outside I would bleach my hair
and then jump in the pool and it would
turn green like that happening yeah I
remember that and that was a thing where
would turn green
I'd have to shave my head and then
why the green wasn't cool it's just well
it's blue president oh yeah turn it
sigelei algae pool yes exactly exactly
it's not a good look especially if you
want to be M&M yeah fair enough I think
I got well nobody likes green M&Ms
you got one Foley yeah did you did you
have braces when you were a kid area on
your legs Ron Michael run he got braces
I did yes the name of your orthodontist
oh I don't know but he was on dude there
was a thing about 990s orthodontist
where my name is fast-food mine was in
his house you're just like Park in his
driveway there are like a dog a lot of
it was wide open back yeah what the
family does anybody watching these from
Dennis - yeah edweird my guy was sucking
so much gas like he was an alternate
always sixty-five between 65 and 70 like
an older God's too old I did anybody
wore it like he was fine with it and he
seemed sharp and all that [ __ ] and then
one day like I showed up and he just had
jet black hair yeah and just never
addressed it and was high as a kite and
was taking off my rubber bands and
putting on new ones and was so [ __ ]
blazed he put he took on the bed and it
came through so he hooked you and it
went through like he was piercing my lip
what took it out and just was like
hooked and mopped it up and told his
assistant to finish and I just didn't
get anything that was nothing happened I
would not I would never happen ever lip
through like the bottom of my lip it
went through all the way through it was
so he like yanked it so violently it
pierced that much [ __ ] he was on
[ __ ] Pluto at the end he was yeah he
was on yeah just a wild guy yeah out of
nowhere and it's like nineties world
like they were just playing it fast and
I don't think it was like it was because
it wasn't like that was a lot of cash
being a lot of cash and was like not
checked in cuz it was like kind of like
elective if you wanted an orthodontist
like you didn't always have to go to an
or that so no did I do this in the
garage you know what I mean it was like
very [ __ ] well what
I'm gonna rain racket because since then
you know then it was an elective thing
that you know if you wanted to look
better sure what you do and now they're
like if you don't have that rate to your
head yeah you got one last question
Kippy I got one more let's see what do
you want to defense I'm not sure if well
then I got I got two quick ones for you
have you ever celebrated a birthday at
an Applebee's - not Dave & Buster's
recently while doing coke alright he's
just in he's [ __ ] trash in the
Palisades Center Oh buddy
when levity live is yeah we used to go
there Monday nights and just get to for
once play video games and just be like
we act out Cooper one drinks the bowling
alley would do that to was like dollar
beers and we would all just go get like
[ __ ] plots ya know if your coke
dealer had a happy hour or so down to
four ones eight balls or one key bump
let's do it probably actually yeah this
is Ben are you garbage is our good
friend Mike Cannon just one time you can
hear him every week on the Irish goodbye
podcast and he has a special out right
now on YouTube called life begins Mike
you have anything else you want to plug
maybe long-term the album's coming out
that's right this Friday I don't know
when this is just me out on Monday so a
week from ok perfect so the album is out
now life begins waddle by a shell on
YouTube that's free it's got about 30
minutes to stand up and then the album
has about 25 27 more minutes guy that
support stream it whatever the [ __ ] you
got to do and thank you I am my cannon
so Corey I watch the special it's really
cool you did it in a [ __ ] awesome
what you first of all you did it
yourself so like if you do support
comedy I'm you a lot of you probably
already know Mike but if you do support
comedy go check it out it's really he
did it himself it's really funny and the
way you did it is really cool with like
the interview with like the other the
interstitial don't like they call me
when Jim Norton Bobby Kelly rich Voss
Keith Robinson it's federally v Brendan
says yeah really drops off yeah that's
why I left him out of it started with
one little face that he makes when you
tell them a story his milky water it's
really funny check it out support on me
it's it's really good I wash it it was
great thank
hippie guys Kevin Ryan comedy calm Kevin
Ryan comedy on all social media and as
well as guys please rate and review this
podcast on iTunes Spotify stitcher
wherever you listen to the podcast it's
important that we do it in the first
week and tell tell a [ __ ] friend share
with somebody you know goddamnit
yeah H Foley calm you can also follow me
at instagrams on Foley Grahams and on
Twitter and H folding eyes there's
nothing on that on that website fully
key bumps I google it doesn't even come
up as website doesn't come up first if
you google it that's our [ __ ] who
made that for you Tyler sure H listen
guys please that could be said shut a
podcast rate review and subscribe we
love you Mike thank you so much goodbye
see ya